California Governor Gavin Newsom
announcing a statewide stay-at-home
order for nearly 40 million people who
live there a social contract here people
I think recognize the need to do more
and to meet this moment people will
self-regulate their behavior we will
have social pressure and that will
encourage people to do the right thing
just a nod and look saying hey maybe you
should reconsider just being out there
on the beach being 22 strong at a park
well let's bring on our panel on that
news dr. Manny Alvarez this year senior
managing editor for Health News and a
Fox News contributor and dr. oz also
joining us host of the dr. Oz Show
appreciate both of your time this
morning so dr. asked you first
what did you make of the state of
California saying to everyone stay at
home well I was doing news last night
with the Los Angeles Fox affiliate and
it was remarkable to see how they
responded and which was basically we
expected this because we were already
doing it there wasn't a lot of outcry
for look on social media most people
said thank goodness
Gavan newsstand demonstrated leadership
did what we always read it to have
happened he basically took the
stragglers Folkestone the bubble and
then forced what everyone wanted to
happen and my son Oliver was you know
it's jr. harbor got of course the school
ceased operations at least for the rest
of this year because it could be covert
19 penned an op-ed piece last night for
the Washington Examiner sort of saying
hey my generation has got to own up we
can be this is our moment to be the
greatest generation to and that's what
Gavin Newson's trying to say the young
people who are in the bubble don't
really understand that there are a huge
problem because they don't know they're
sick their symptoms are pretty trivial
and so they are out there being vectors
for infections and we're realizing more
and more that of people who are
asymptomatic or pre symptomatic or a
real issue and it's the duration of it
quarantines probably not 14 days it
should be three weeks if we're gonna do
it right because in China they found
people were sending expressed and
shedding virus four weeks after they
were ill well you never know they might
they might extend that when the White
House has the briefing an hour from now
but dr. mani if it's necessary there is
it necessary in other states I think so
I think the social distancing and
everything that dr. oz said in regards
to not making these young people vectors
for communities I mean if you look at
some of the death rates of course
they're affecting older population
people over 65 people with underlying
medical conditions so if you eliminate
the vector that social vector of young
people not paying attention and I think
they're getting the message by the way
I'm gonna give them a lot of credit I
think people young people are getting
the message they're staying home college
students and so on I think they're
getting the message but I think we have
to continue with that pressure and bring
it to communities that are not doing it
in fact dr. Burks gentlemen was on with
Bret Baier last night a special report
talked about keeping the pressure on and
how the future is really in our hands
listen we know what to do now to stop
the spread of the virus I think are we
as an American people as a community of
individuals who care for each other
willing to make this personal sacrifice
that changed this course of the virus so
it's not 25 million infected it's not
five million infected but maybe 50,000
to 150,000 infected that's the
possibility that we hold in our hands
dr. oz we are now several days into the
15-day guidelines from the White House I
know we can't go through every single
community but but big picture how do you
feel we're doing in terms of progress
you know the cities like New York which
now represent one-third of all the virus
load for the country are still suffering
other parts of the country have been
accelerated as quickly I think we're
seeing that earlier action before you've
got the loss of the of the virus you
can't contain it anymore
works so I'm hopeful that most the
country will be spared and we're
cracking down hard here in New York in
California as you mentioned earlier but
I'll tell you the most impressive bit of
news on this entire pandemic front
it was the paper from Marseille France
LA yesterday that many and I am sure my
colleagues are all stunned by they took
two old drugs a malaria drug and a
z-pack it's used for infections at
antibiotic and they demonstrated they
could reduce the viral load on people
within three days and all the virus was
gone in six days in
that's true and that's what the
president was speaking about yesterday
that dramatically changes everything
then all of a sudden we can suffocate
this virus much more rapidly it'll
behave more like the traditional
seasonal influenza and a lot of the pain
that we're anticipating going through
might not be needed dr. Manny are you
hopeful and optimistic as well dr. oz
puts an important element on the table
there absolutely I think that between
the programs that are being instituted
and just like dr. oz I'm very bullish on
this chloroquine protocol I think it has
shown at least in preliminary results
that it does decreases the viral load it
has a good scientific functionality when
it comes to viruses entering the cell
and is a drug that we have a lot of
experience with so I think that if we
continue and show promise that this is a
pathway to treatment or to prevention is
going to really change and make that
whole window a little bit shorter dr. oz
I want to throw up the White House
15-day guidelines because we are about
to hear from the White House again they
continue to alter and change their
guidelines or we've just seen them
evolve period over time but of course
the gatherings of more than 10 people we
are told to avoid those home-schooling
when possible avoid discretionary travel
avoid eating and drinking at bars
restaurants happening cuz so many have
shut down quarantine entire household if
one member is diagnosed focus on
protecting the vulnerable
obviously that message continues as well
but for so many dr. oz and I'm sure you
walk down the street or you get phone
calls from your page people can drive
themselves nuts with trying to keep
their house clean trying to prevent
their kids from seeing other kids when
they go out to play for a few minutes I
mean what is your message this morning
about how we can stay sane through all
this by while also protecting our family
you know over the last 24 hours
there I've seen a massive transition
from a period where doctors were yelling
and screaming with nurses and other
health experts say we got to pay
attention we got to get on this virus
and now I think we mostly are feeling
more optimistic than the average
American is I'm seeing more my late
friends and colleagues I'm hearing from
viewers who are more panicked than I
think is appropriate based on what I
know and I'm hoping many and other
doctors will be loud about this if we're
getting out
the mystic as doctors as clinicians you
should be feeling better about it as
well now we are seeing some potential
benefit by from in the Investor
community right they didn't sink the
stock market yesterday when we continue
to have worst number because everyone
has sort of expected this is the course
but I feel more bullish about this
process that I have in a long time in
part cuz this new data but also because
the government has finally done what we
knew would work and it will take time
you know when you're putting in when
someone we're gonna cause pain you can
do it fast you can do it slow you can
rip off the band-aid or do it slowly we
finally did we did it slowly but now the
band-aids on so let's manage they can
take the emotional issues we don't we
don't want to have the emotional
problems outweigh the true clinical risk
dr. mani do you share that optimism i I
do and you know for many for a couple of
days now I want it to be very optimistic
you know sometimes we become optimistic
and we get criticized by other by other
people because we say oh they're not
taking this serious we are taking this
serious we're you know we want the
social distancing we wanted the research
to go we want the federal government to
be prepared with any kind of potential
issues that they need to do and we want
the governors and the states to follow
through but we I am getting optimistic I
think that you know the shortages of
things that you know people are
predicting is gonna be you know it's not
going to be real in the short-term let's
say I think that these protocols
clinical protocols are going to make
some changes which are positive I look
at all the research that's being done by
biotech companies whether it's an you
know AB the plasma therapy where there
are these medications I think there's a
lot of good work coming out of this and
I think that we're gonna beat this
alright gentlemen we've got under a
minute so real quick lightning round to
both of you dr. Oz first about a week
ago when you talked about that balance
in terms of taking it seriously but not
panicking there were a lot of people
predicting look hospitals are about to
face this the dire consequences it's
gonna be so many new patients do you
think we're starting to turn the corner
we're starting to flatten that curve
that dr. Fox you talked about it's
impossible to tell and I don't know
about supplies my Hospital New York
Presbyterian is getting squeezed I'm
looking for masks and there's some
things we haven't thought about like the
blood banks are saying wait a minute you
know people still have to donate blood
for emergency cases some of the blood
products don't last that long so there
are things that we still need to manage
in the supply chain
but we will suffocate this pandemic
virus and it will not take us more than
the four weeks that most people expect
even if we have eight or ten weeks or
pain dr. mani last word
well I again I echo what dr. Oz says we
know we have to be vigilant we have to
keep the pressure on and we have to keep
the social distancing now we have to
focus on people that are staying home
children people with mental disabilities
that always concerns me a lot because
you know quarantine folks like that
sometimes it's a little problematic so I
think we have to multitask in this time
of need
stay inside those are doctor's orders we
got two of the best doctors right there
thank you for your advice this morning
we appreciate it thanks to both of you